it's a play Capcom exclusive yellow is
power 98.3 man bootleg cab up in here
we've got my dude
he had the song of the week last week
that collard greens joint oxymoron
coming so we got schoolboy q yeah what
up man I appreciate you too man
q man trying to stay awake today talking
there's like a video I guess you fell
asleep in an interview again rabbit yeah
yeah I was but barely remember that
remember what happened it was it was bad
man drunk man you see what I did when I
came here I was always talking about all
right so let's talk about the album
oxymoron
you got a in my opinion habits &
contradictions was one of the best
projects come out of last year and this
is going to actually be an album that
you got into the stores and buyers yes
yes I mean I wouldn't say it's your
debut I feel like the last two prices
technically albums but I guess in this
day and age those were mixtapes you know
so um let's talk about the debut album
man what's up with it man who you got on
that thing when it got Pharrell on
production got Danny Brown a sir rocky
of course my count
yeah um I've been trying to get fit do
you miss me do what you did bananas yeah
yeah we got another one two in the cut
Kendrick actually liked the song a whole
lot oh you probably tell you from you
know this Kendrick have that like like
like oh yeah yeah yo Q I'm gonna need
that man if he wanted something for me
you can have it that's Kendrick like
I'll be able to say damn kid you just
took a song for me he never took a song
for me though we traded beats before but
we never like exchanged songs or
anything
I mean is it kind of like you've seen
Kendra blow up to be this you know
icon and hip
like he's kind of like the leader of
this new his new hip-hop you know what
I'm saying
like you said like if he wanted a song
you would give it to him I mean what is
it like being with somebody throughout
you know I mean he was kind of like your
little home you don't I'm saying yeah I
mean [__] I mean hey I mean I'm really
little homey you know when it comes to
music cuz he took off before me and he's
a lot lot bigger and his fanbase is my
brother to my book that's what I'm
saying that you've seen the progression
first yeah it's just motivation you
ought to mean you see somebody you was
with from the start like I said member
when we were sharing food like five
dollars you know what I mean like that
from the start like it's not just on
some rap music got together and like we
really like came up together in his game
you know what I mean to see him take off
and for me to be the next you know what
I mean it's a little shaky and it's like
what this is really for me too it's like
you know what I mean just like I know
what could really really happen I never
thought this day would really come I was
just really wrapping into he like kind
of forced me into this position you know
what I mean by taking you on a road
seeing life in a whole different
perspective you know I mean I had to eat
so you say you have of course Danny
Brown and a sapper dudes that you've
been rocking with what is the dynamic
with you and a set you guys rock with
each other a long way yeah um just
homies man we like clothes we like
ladies we both the same person you know
to me we we speak our mind we you know
what I'm saying it is what it is I don't
know it's just a connection we had it
wasn't even before we even like well he
was a fan of my first year I mean I
don't even know it was music like that
he just shot up past me like with two
songs you not i mean like pesos and
purple swag just you know what I mean
like I'm like yo and I'm saying but I
was already cool with him prior to that
like me I got cool him on just vibing
and connecting with him and then I ended
up liking his music when he dropped the
project and it was just
over from there um like when it came to
Kendrick you know like with each project
I feel like you could hear a lot of
growth each project kind of had I would
say like a like a theme you know what
where are you going with this new
project compared to the last two this
album honestly I never said this in
interview 2
this album is really it's about me
really taking care of my daughter word
yeah so what this whole album is really
about it's about me taking care of my
daughter in crib history from 1969 to
present you know to me that's what this
album is really about I mean you know my
daughter's four years old and I I could
remember saying my daughter needs some
shoes and just I'm like three times
because every time I actually it's your
favorite daddy song she just says my
daughter needs me shoes so I made sure I
kept putting that in song I got a
shocker for the beginning of the song
depending if the label let me do it well
I appreciate that's what I appreciate
about Kendricks kind of brought this get
back to hip-hop artists really use a
skit in the runway Kendrick and then UK
it's not even the skin is music is this
like in hip-hop there's been
historically sectioned off in a track
like yeah I'm keeping it all in the
track like it's not gonna say skate
right it's all in the song Sarang hope
is part of the part of the book
basically part of the book oxymoron of
course everyone is you know fans of
yours they know your history with you
know our seas and stuff is that also a
theme in the yeah you know I'm just
saying like I don't really don't like
saying I sold oxy are saying stuff like
that to promote the album
I rather people hear it right it didn't
take like oh okay you see what I'm
saying someone who's sold like you know
oxys like you and
now there's you know the Mali craze and
you know Kendra kind of did yeah Mike it
might take somebody a night like you
know like like how do you feel about
them tamale situation out there I mean
you're puffy you know IV that's
Kendricks opinion yummy we make two
different styles in music to my to
different type of people so I'm actually
I'm with what he's saying and I'm not
what what are you saying I support
whatever he does you know what I mean if
he went up to me if he came up to me and
be like yo I really want you off of
Miley art I don't want you to touch my I
don't don't get me wrong I'm not
addicted to Molly I don't buy Miley
everyday or like recreation or like that
yeah but if he asked me stay away from
me no leave it alone I know I had seen
before we had talked about this before
that you had stopped sipping on the
drink man I relapsed a little bit I mean
for the most part I can't lie I can't
see any rely to my friends they act like
they can catch me with a double cup
right somebody that seen me walking
somewhere you know what I mean or like I
didn't have my security holding it I
relapsed you know I love collard greens
man when are we gonna have the album in
stores one can we go buy a lot of people
been waiting for the debut look
schoolboy Travis said this either we
haven't put the date out because we
still working on samples so okay that's
the dependent when the sample may clears
like one song one or two songs depending
when it clearly album for the most part
is done it's done it's done you know I
mean I'm just working on stuff just to
get stuff you know you never use the
record your best records at the end of
the album right on to me because you get
to hear it you get to see what's missing
yeah we really dissect it so right now I
just got a record from Jay co2 so
looking like a beat
yeah yeah you know I'm just working on
that right now just just one record
to the sample clears his story up in
hip-hop you know this is mom this is our
first time doing this major thing like
say we come from the indie indie come up
to grind shake no to doughboys you know
like it's a whole new die never knew
like I've only been to the office like
three times like Interscope office you
know what I mean like I'm not really I
really don't know what really goes on in
a major system all I know is that they
tell me we got to get the sample clean
last time you were in town I want to say
we were here you were ASAP I think you
slipped on stinky so bad played it off
so well though it hurt is so bad though
you have no idea I've landed on my pinky
like sideways it was bad it was let's
not slip tonight in Mesa a lot of
Mormons in Mesa - oh man so watch out
keep the drinking of in the bus Mesa
police is racist oh man we flew out here
today's I set out to q-not - Kendrick
whoo-hoo custon every single known a man
in this joint
yeah I don't even like what's funny is
though I don't speak Spanish but I knew
you don't either
just like how do you know he's like
those are the Spanish words everybody
knows right now like I don't see I you
put a Spanish verse lady or I made it
make sense and that's getting a rap like
he got me hot right now schoolboy q we
appreciate you better